löst in meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen hier zu einer
weiteren folge munter legend an meinem
geburtstag
viele haben mich bei twitter befragten
stimmten ein zwanzigsten geburtstag
heißt weil du hast ja gefragt dass du
deine licht man kann momentan bis
maximal 14 aufsteigen gerichte den licht
tempel maximalstufe 20 zu erhöhen
okay weil ich hoffe neben sonnenlicht
tempels letzte mal eben hier hin und
dann kann ich den hier kann ich den ich
auch jetzt verbessern mittlerweile eine
million ich habe nicht eine million von
amt viel hat mich bruder gefragt
es geht mit der abyss stilla marge
dürfte geburtstag und du hast mal gesagt
unserem 20 fixfertig video ja ich habe
heute geburtstag ich werde heute sechs
jahre alt aber ich habe mir gedacht ich
trotzdem eine folge monster legions raus
weil ich habe ein wenig weiter gespielt
da seht ihr schon ich bin level 29 habe
komplett andere gold und obst werte da
oben meine arbeit hast gerade beide
beschäftigt ich glaube die machen das
war eben ein bisschen schneller dass
sich die beide mal eben im staat habe
hier und ich habe auch neue monster
meine lieben freund und zwar habe ich
einerseits hier habe ich hoch ratio dann
habe ich alles und ich ihr seht schon
diese alle level 30 die ich mir nämlich
hoch gepumpt habe mit essen die kann man
ja füttern uns weiter fort und ich
kämpfe und ich habe mir gerade gekauft
und da ich jetzt den lichtkegel
errichtet habe kann ich den ja auch noch
mal ein bisschen höher machen und zwar
nicht einfach geschaut welches pokémon
welches pokémon center welches monster
sieht ganz cool aus und sieht gefährlich
aus und warte ich werd mal eben hier
eine attacke vergessen ich werde dir
vergessen damit ich dir eben erlernen
kann
ich hab gedacht welche sieht ganz cool
aus und das hat mich so ein bisschen an
nicht an nicht an juli erinnert sondern
es gibt ein pokemon das sieht genau so
aus das ist halt nicht dieses feuer
feuer fährt wie heißt das normal man
leichter als das ist sonnenfeuer
fertigen irgendwie das ist zwar vom
design und so komplett nicht gleich aber
daran hat mich irgendwie erinnert keine
ahnung warum deswegen hab ich mir das
geholt und es ist auch ein recht gutes
pokémon ich werde jetzt nämlich
kommen die neue fähigkeiten erlernen
macht erstmal und ich glaube ich kann
jetzt auch auf level 30 bringen und dann
habe ich nämlich achter muss immer den
den licht tempel hier 900.000 gold habe
ich nicht aber ich habe noch ein
bisschen von den diamanten deswegen hole
ich mir jetzt eben noch ein bisschen
gold einfach oder baue ich jetzt mal
eben den donner tempel aus und den licht
tempel dann mach ich das ganze auch mal
eben hier ein bisschen schneller und man
kann ich nämlich ihn hier noch ein
bisschen weiter hochleveln so dass wir
nämlich meine lieben freunde da ich
jetzt level 29 oder 30 bin und als ich
dann level 28 erreicht hat also ich
spiele dieses spiel immer wenn ich so
irgendwie abends im bett liege oder so
einfach nie die attacke nämlich nicht
wenn ich abends im bett liege und
einfach ein bisschen langeweile hat
schwierig das ein bisschen gewissen die
monster aufleveln und so weil ich finde
gerade dieser reiz an dem spiel ist
einfach die tatsache dass ich da einfach
so monster kreuzen kann und dann kommen
neue monster raus wenn ihr versteht was
ich meine ich meine bei pokemon was auch
so da gab es dieses pokémon zucht
gebäude wo man zwei pokémon hin tun
konnte übrigens es ist gerade irgendwie
10 uhr oder so deswegen sehe ich
bisschen müde aus da gab es auch schon
gucken und hofgebäude da kannst du 2.0
reinpacken
ja genau jetzt kann ich nicht mehr
weiter ausbauen außerdem verbessere ich
kann ihn nicht dann nochmal verbessern
ach komm das machen wir doch mal eben
schnell hier eben fertig stellen und
dann können wir ihnen hier den guten
können wir nämlich noch ein bisschen als
das mein erstes monster was ich will
eben noch ein paar sachen an
also das einzige was mich an diesem
spiel halt einfach mega fasziniert
beziehen wir sind das einzige sondern
unter anderem ist einfach die tatsache
dass man die einzigen dass man so man
hat zu einzelnen monster so ein paar
wenige aber man kann die monster kreuzen
und dann kriegt man so wieder neue
monster das war beispielsweise so als
ich mir hier den allahs geholt das ist
eine kreuzung aus ratio noch einem
anderen 8 ich kann die monster
bearbeiten halte ich kann die bearbeiten
luca rio vom der escheck wirken rio mit
den kern zu mir gleich oder machst du
das mal hier
hallo meine return 89 dann hole ich mir
mal eben hier bei euch noch ein bisschen
was an was haben wir denn ihr altern
lassen
richtig teure sachen die ihr teilweise
die ich hier habe manchmal auch schnell
fertig stellen habe ich hier ein
bisschen was und jetzt kann ich ihnen
hier machen ein bisschen fitter neben
und danach wie mehr
ich hab doch der muss mit 3700 gefüttert
werden alter junge
wie krank jetzt müssen es rein
theoretisch klappen ja das was kommt
dann reicht mir das stufe 33 erst mal
und zwar ist es durch die runen quasi
möglich ist schon hier ist das grüne
gewölbe
da kann ich jetzt beispielsweise monster
von mir ausrüsten dass ich kann jetzt
sagen der u2 dem füge ich jetzt meine
ruhe hinzu irgendwie die ich hier oder
so ich glaube ja genau das geht doch gar
nicht weil ich muss das grüne gewölbe
erste stufe 2 bringen aber ich kann
jetzt beispielsweise die stärkung
hinzufügen dann hat er eine rune das ist
sowas wie wenn man bei ultimate team ich
weiß nicht ob jemand von euch wie vor
ultimate team zockt da kann man spielern
für eine gewisse anzahl von spielen so
zusatzpunkte geben so was wie weiß ich
nicht so was gibt es also eine
steigerung in der geschwindigkeit plus
10 und das hält dann für ein spiel an
oder so so was ähnliches sind die runen
ich möchte es nicht komplett damit
vergleichen aber es ist halt weise eine
stärkung für die monster und das habe
ich jetzt auch schon bei anderen
monstern macht wenn ich beispielsweise
euch mal monster auswählen klicken und
dann mir beispielsweise wo habe ich das
denn gemacht bei bei ihm ist das noch
gesperrt ich glaube sie realisieren
nicht aber hier bei hoh ratio oder seht
ihr schon wenn ich den mal hier auswähle
drehte schon habe ich die runen gold
geschwindigkeit und leben also erhöht
den gold ertrag erhöht die
geschwindigkeit und erhöht das leben des
monsters um 9% ich wollte euch diese
runen einfach nochmal in level in level
eine reihe kriegt man erst ab level 28
ich bin ihr level 29 ist mittlerweile
und wir können jetzt auch in die
dungeons gehen wo es nämlich härtere
kämpfe einfach gibt da habe ich jetzt
letzten schon im boxkampf gehabt wo ein
kompletter saß ich irgendwie eine stunde
dran weil das waren solche monster com
an diesen alle level höher als ich aber
hatte ich werd mal ich werde jetzt auch
mal anstatt maccario ich werde nicht mit
lokalkämpfe ich werde man statt lokal
werde ich jetzt mal hier den meinen
neuen kollegen hier neben den mutu und
dann freunde ich glaube das wird ein
richtig richtig spannender kampf weil
wir alle so ca auf einem level sind auch
gottes ich mir schon richtig viel
eigentlich vogelschlag erst mal hier auf
die ganzen feuer monster das ist schon
mal sehr effektiv da mache ich noch
flutung auf ihn hier hinten drauf
und jetzt kommt's ländern griffnähe
selbstschutz ist auch unnötig
das verstehe ich wieder nicht mehr
wasser attac ist sehr effektiv gegen das
feuer monster aber eine eine eine eine
blatt attacke auch liebe entwickelt das
das verstehe ich irgendwie nicht so ein
bisschen also ihr merkt schon im
gegensatz zu den letzten matches die wm
gespielt haben kriege ich jetzt auch mal
richtig schaden eingefügt von den
gegnern weil ihr seht schon die sind
einfach die beiden puppen die beiden
monster die auf der anderen seite stehen
sind glaube ich vom level 31 31 meine
sind 30 30 33 also ein richtig richtig
richtig richtig ausgeglichenes match
eigentlich aber irgendwie hab ich glaube
ich durch die runen bei mir echten
krassen vorteil weil ihr wisst ja
beispielsweise hier er hat glaube ich
eine rune oder so kann ich jetzt mal
angreifen und vor allem wenn ich jetzt
eben nehme der ist jetzt glaube ich
jetzt angreifen
jetzt kommt erstmal hier jetzt habe ich
schon gewonnen weil ich mal sind
doppelte ohrfeige bad bad bruder du bist
oder belohnungen
ich hoffe ich habe eine rune damit ich
euch mal zeigen kann was ich mit so
einer ruhe machen kann
hhg kommen neun versuchen möchte ich das
einmal zeigen wie man das macht mit nach
ohne damit ihr 100 fotos kommen nochmal
bruder eine rune ist nein ich bin kein
richtig will eine verdammte
knoten 7 abgeschlossen dass diese
belohnung erhalten 10.000 gold ist ja
sehr nice m und zwar kann ich jetzt
einfach acht erfolge ich hatte nur ein
erfolg würde bestimmt nicht so welche
prag ein erfolg ist neu erfolgt ob gar
keine neuen davor jetzt kann ich hier
beispielsweise bei udo einfach hingehen
stärkung stufe eins habe ich schon und
jetzt gehe ich beispielsweise einfach
mal auf ausbaustufe ein sondern seht ihr
schon wenn ich das jetzt auch wieder
verändern sich da links die werte das
heißt die ausdauer ist jetzt ein
bisschen besser von dem und am liebsten
würde ich ihm auch die stufe 2
hinzufügen aber dafür muss ich meine
ruhe gebäude ausrüsten
eine million gold habe ich eh nicht und
stufe 1 30 habe ich auch nicht also das
werden wir wahrscheinlich heute nicht
mehr einkriegen
aber die runen sind einfach so ganz grob
gesagt ihr habt einfach eine sache die
könnt ihr ein monster geben gab meine
nachbarn ich bin behindert also vor
allem falls meine nachbarin kam sie
heute darüber so um 8 uhr
lukas ich gute zum geburtstag hier die
mir so eine tafel schokolade geschenkt
hatte ich gucken ob ich die noch finden
freunde ich hatte sonst immer sondern so
eine kiste bei mir im zimmer wo ich die
süßigkeiten drin hatte aber die hab ich
jetzt um funktionalisiert zu einer kiste
wo ich so ich habe einfach so klopapier
und alles auf vorrat gekauft guckt euch
mal diese kiste jetzt hier an
da schießt man darunter sind irgendwo
die süßigkeit weil ich schaue mir das
mal eben an freunde
das macht keinen sinn das kann ich ja
keine ahnung also meine nachbarin ist
einfach halt dies halt schon 80 oder 100
oder 200 oder so und dieses mega klar in
amerika gilt und somit der letzten den
fahrstuhl mit unterhalten ich bin leben
und dem schiri aber wir sind hier bei
monster legions for sale ich gönne mir
ich hab ja ich hab einfach echt sei
wenig ressourcen einfach nur noch kann
ich hier noch etwas aufbessern oder so
dass das kind noch eben schnell machen
dann mach ich das noch irgendwie schnell
fertig dann kann ich nämlich auch hier
glaube ich noch ein bisschen zittern
oder ich brauch noch mehr von dem gemüse
und möchte am liebsten einfach das
horatio noch so ein bisschen gefüttert
wird weil deine von monster ich muss den
tempel auf besser dass ich hab nicht
eine million man nehme ich würde einfach
sagen wir gehen dann noch mal in die
dungeons rein weil bei den dungeon
krieg ich am ende hier seht ihr am ende
da kommt immer so teilweise monster noch
monster noch monster und am ende ist hat
er hier ganz rechts zähne da seht als er
dieses monster vorne was ich gerade hier
an gesund habe gegen den meinte ich was
er bleibt weiter voran dagegen gehen
habe ich diesen blöden kampf absolviert
wo ich eine stunde dran daran saß weil
ich die ganze zeit verkackt habe der ist
mega gut dieser typ aber ich möchte
einfach am ende dieses iphone von diesem
von diesem monster deswegen das wäre so
hammer einfach ok schon wieder recht
ausgeglichen aber ich lass das jetzt mal
einfach ich muss mir auch das ist ja so
ähnlich wie mit mit pokemon einfach mit
diesem was halt eine starke attacke ist
was ein schwacher tag ist und so weiter
und ich muss mir diese tabelle echt mal
irgendwie den kopf rein kriegen das
jetzt stark oder schwach gegen was
anderes suchen macht doch nicht gift
schauer alter jung ich hasse diese gifte
punkt man auch schon mal gehasst dass du
einfach pro runde irgendwas abgezogen
was ob du jetzt mal ein pence nach drei
runden oder ob du feurig freue wie ich
bin blöd oder ob du irgendwie etwas gibt
es da oder ob du irgendwie bremst oder
ob du verlierst bist oder was gibt's da
noch elektrizität etikettiert ok guck
mal hier
denn erst die erste miss papier haben
wir völlig alter wie kann ich denn
solche hässlichen viecher mit müssens
bafin im vergleich bringen so uta oder
oder wie dieses ding heißt gefällt mir
bisher echt richtig gut
ich weiß nicht warum also die attacken
sind nicht so nice aber irgendwie ich
glaube aus true to the who oder wieder
hier auf jeden fall ordentlich was raus
und weil ich durch bin jetzt damit
angreifen oder bin ich müde ist
malouda irgendwie heißer denn je ist gar
kein geld hätten
damit nehmen wir eben doppelte ohrfeige
hier gegen die einem ist es passiert
aber nur noch eine miss passt dahin habe
ich im din den james dean okay das war
krass diese einem ist es passt da hinten
die letzte hat gerade einmal dinge
abgezogen bekommen sondern so ein
bisschen kaffee abgezogen bekommt durch
das gift und dann nochmal durch die
verbrennung wie keine ausdauer wo ich
gerne aus der wiesche
aufladen so legt sich auf kuba der sich
einfach selbst getötet durch verbrennen
und gift alter das richtig
ok ich weiß nicht was in dieser bottle
ist mit diesem fragezeichen drauf aber
es wäre auf jeden fall weiß wenn ich die
kom kom kom kom kom eine model oder eine
runde gondel oder ohne bottle rune
bottle nein komm gib mir doch jetzt
einfach hier da kommen doch immer nur
diese blöden sachen die garuda heraus
dass er doch noch einen versuch geklickt
eigentlich wollte ich nur die ruhe
einsammeln aber glaubt mir jetzt gehe
ich jetzt noch mal eben hier in das
wohnen gewerbe rein und rüstet die
monster eben noch hier mit den runen aus
die ich noch habe ach nee das geht jetzt
gerade gar nicht weil jetzt hab ich hier
gruppen stärkung noch drauf und dann
mehr kann ich glaube ich für diese folge
noch gar nicht wieder machen ich könnte
hier noch ausrüsten ja ich kann hier
noch eben ausrüsten dass man noch ein
bisschen schneller
und dann
hambach alles was wir glaube ich hier
können wir noch ausrüsten sehe ich
gerade das kriegen wir noch eben schnell
hin dass man auch mal eben dass krieg
nicht schneller gemacht weil ich nicht
mehr so viele
james habe die ich mir damals gegönnt
habe sonst würde ich sagen meine lieben
freunde war es das dann auch schon
wieder für diese folge freunde folge das
kann sich gar nicht wenn es euch
gefallen hat würde ich mich sehr sehr
dollar bei einer bewertung freuen wenn
ihr mir gratulieren wollt dann und dann
sehen uns im nächsten video wieder ihr
seht den download link von der von dem
spiel in der beschreibung da will ich
mich freuen wenn ihr den entwicklern man
beruf da last oder irgendwas oder keine
ahnung ob das geht
hier findet man netzwerke den in der
beschreibung ihr findet mein equipment
in der beschreibung und wir sehen uns
nachher bei den commands wieder wenn ich
das denn schaffe oder wenn die command
schon gekommen sind oder so keine ahnung
ich vergesse was gesagt hat